this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer steve watts
ratchet and clank rift apart is a game
about counterparts
in this strange new setting everyone has
a doppelganger but their circumstances
have changed them
ratchet's new alternate dimensional
counterpart river may have had a harder
life than him but it's shaped her
personally in surprising ways but she's
still the same heroic person at heart
the same can be said for rift apart the
new generation of hardware has made some
dramatic changes for the better but in a
very welcome and comforting way this is
the ratchet and clank you've come to
know and love
release i wonder how much nefarious is
paying these guys
not nearly enough the title may be
ratchet and clank but rivet is the real
star here
ratchet and his robot buddy clank are
the template that helps inform what we
learn about rivet and her own journey
and the vast majority of rift apart
takes place in her universe
she also seems to get slightly more
playtime even if the stages are split
roughly evenly
after a brief tutorial in ratchet's
megalopolis the bumbling but sinister dr
nefarious transports himself and the
titular duo to another dimension
when nefarious gets there he finds that
it's ruled by emperor nefarious
the emperor is conspicuously absent at
the moment so our doctor nefarious just
helps himself to the throne
meanwhile ratchet and clank are
separated and clank is picked up by the
freedom fighter rivet
most of the game centers around these
dimensional counterparts who are not
exactly twins but rather similar
characters with different names and
slightly different personalities
rift apart rewards longtime fans with
little nudging winks on how the
alternative characters break from my
expectations
ratchet naturally thinks this mysterious
lady lombax has taken clank but
thankfully the heroes in strife because
of a misunderstanding trope is resolved
quickly and they begin working together
but this game belongs to rivet not just
because it takes place in her dimension
but because she's a fantastic addition
to the larger ratchet and clank universe
i would love to play a standalone river
game set in this or any other dimension
part of that is the performance of
jennifer hale as rivet who introduces a
disarming amount of emotional heft
wow it's been my lifelong dream to
operate a drill a hundred times
bigger than me really that is very
specific
specific goals are achievable goals
unlike ratchet rivet has experienced a
string of defeats from the oppressive
nefarious regime and hail imbues the
character with little tinges of
self-doubt and loneliness even as she
maintains her heroic determination
this is a character like ratchet who
fights for justice but she just hasn't
had a partner like clank
ultimately the story is a sweet natured
but relatively conventional one about
friendship and trust
elevated above its conventions by hail
and the surrounding cast
despite the fact that the dual heroes
barely ever talk face to face they share
one pool of equipment
having one weapon wheel between
characters ensures that you can switch
between your favorite guns without
having to pause the fun and look for
what you need
ratchet is known for its inventive
munitions and almost all of the weapons
are new they largely fit into familiar
archetypes but the ps5 dual sense makes
a massive difference to how the weapons
behave
for the most part the dual sense lets
you control different functions with
half or full pull of the right trigger
the negetron collider for example is an
energy beam that will charge up and then
hold the charge at half pull
and fire at full pole these functions
seem deceptively simple but once i got
into the rhythm it felt completely
natural to call up functions without a
second four
for example a favorite of mine the black
hole storm is a gatling gun that spins
up at half pull and then fires at full
with a little experimentation
you can keep it spinning without firing
by easing up on the trigger saving ammo
but keeping the weapon at the ready it's
that kind of smart implementation that
makes the dual sense functionality more
impactful than a mere gimmick
like past ratchet games the weapon
upgrades come in two complementary
tracks
the first simply upgrades your weapon
through use the other is obtained by
purchasing nodes on an upgrade tree with
raritanium a limited resource scattered
throughout the planets
the upgrade tree unlocks more nodes as
you upgrade the weapon through use so
the two systems sync together very well
some of the weapons feel a little off
with how many uses it takes to earn an
upgrade
the ricochet gun which bounces off your
enemies like a pimple upgraded much
later than some of my other weapons even
with heavy use
and very specialized or situational
weapons like the bombardier or cold snap
are achingly slow to upgrade
rift apart is an action platformer and
insomniac has built further on its
already robust traversal options from
past games
complementing the usual suit of jumps
rocket boots and contextual swinging
mechanics are two new moves
the rift tether and the phantom dash the
rift tether pulls you into a dimensional
hole in such a way that it looks as if
the world is moving around you while the
phantom dash lets you phase out a
reality and functions like a dodge roll
these combine with the existing ratchet
and clank mainstays to make for some
breathless harrowing set pieces as you
transfer from rail grinding to war
running to rift tethering with reckless
abandon
even better these traversal tools sing
when you apply them in combat scenarios
especially in tougher encounters where
you're swarmed with enemies the rift
tethers let you close distance or get
away for a breather quickly and the
phantom dash feels different than a
standard jumping dodge because it breaks
the continuity of your fire
including the charge for weapons like
the negetron collider whether you want
to risk a dodging jump to hold your fire
or play it safe with a phantom dash is
the kind of split second decision that
makes the combat feel exciting
not all of the traversal is quite as
satisfying though a few times you have
to jump on the back of a
pterodactyl-like creature named trudy to
navigate a particular stage or snag some
collectibles
while it's seemingly intended to add
variety the beast feels sluggish and
temperamental compared to the smooth and
intuitive controls of ratchet and rivet
these segments are short enough that
they don't detract too much from the
over experience but they stand out as a
weak spot when compared to the rest
more successfully insomniac mixes in
moments of variety with two types of
puzzle stages
a series of clank puzzles has you
placing orbs with different effects to
guide a constantly running line of clank
possibilities
lemmings like towards the goal a more
action-oriented puzzle section features
an adorable robot named glitch and has
you unlocking and then zapping viruses
to open computer systems
these interstitial segments aren't deep
enough to support their own games but
they are welcome brief change of pace in
this one
those puzzles are also entirely
skippable if they're not to your taste
the challenges and trophies aren't gated
by difficulty level and you can use
accessibility options like the slow down
mechanic to finesse your way past tricky
parts
ratchet and clank rifter park comes
across as a game that's comfortable in
his own skin and unafraid to let you
engage on your own terms
all of this is delivered in such a
refined recognizable package that the
technical prowess on display doesn't
often call attention to itself
the rift tethers refresh your
perspective almost instantaneously
scenes and gameplay blends so seamless
together you might often miss the
transition
pocket dimensions hidden throughout
planets that open an entirely separate
environment that feel like they've
punched a hole in the fabric of space
a couple of particular planets that you
switch back and forth between entire
realities in a snap
and load times are non-existent either
so fast that you never notice
or hidden behind scene transition it
makes the whole game feel cinematic and
harmonious in a natural
unself-conscious way if you do pause for
a moment to take it in
it will be to gork at the stunning
visuals the environments are richly
detailed and differentiated both the
enemies and major characters have the
kind of stretchy expressive face and
inventive design elements you'd see in
an animated feature film
each time i reach a new planet i will
take a few moments to rotate the camera
and soak it all in
it's just astounding to look at even if
that level of visual fidelity isn't
center stage when you're in the thick of
the action
ratchet and clank rift apart is flashy
and technically impressive without
feeling self-important it's just as
silly sweet and earnest as the ratchet
and clank series tends to be while the
new generation of hardware makes his
entry look and play better than ever
like the heroes and villains in their
dimensional counterparts this one may
appear different or carry itself with a
new accent but there's an underlying
truth to the person underneath
at its core it's still your trusty old
pals on another grand space adventure
and that's what's important
[Music]
all right now let's get to nefarious
these schools are useless
this is what i get for giving my
assistant paid fraternity quickly
we cannot let nefarious overuse the
dimensionator
we must lower his defenses
[Music]
you